Today's episode of what if discussed is brought to you by policy
genius?
At what point will we attain to status? Well,
remember now we're talking about centuries to maybe a thousand years into the
future. This means building the first star ships.
So we're going to go far beyond the solar system and reach out to the nearby
stars.
[inaudible] so, Pete, how are you doing today?
I'm good. How are you doing?
You seem surprised that I'm asking you how you're doing.
Is an odd way to start, but not until you say it every week,
but it seemed like you were putting me on the spot for some reason.
I mean, in this case, I was actually concerned.
I am concerned with how you're doing, but more in the context of energy,
how are you feeling energetic? Yeah.
Ah, well, I mean you here, we're sitting in August of 2020, and uh,
just the hope is this the tail end of the pandemic? Really? I don't know.
I think like a lot of people who are working from home,
not everybody's working from home, but I am a lot of people are taxed. They're,
uh, they're, they've expended a lot of their energy.
And I mean,
I think most people would answer the question the same way most people feel they
don't have enough energy,
they could use more energy because at the end we're all energy,
including our planet.
Okay. Now I see where you're going with this. You're talking about.
And because of para probably the, uh, the topic of today's show,
everything is energy.
Everything is energy. And in this case,
how planets are sort of categorize according to the [inaudible] scale,
which is something we'll get into later,
there are type one type two type three civilizations,
and it's according to how much energy they can harness from in this case type
two that you can harness from the sun.
We have done a few car to chef scale, like videos on, uh,
what if, um, and I don't recall, are we a type one?
Well, bad news. We're not a type one yet. We're actually type zero,
which is not something that depressed. Yeah, it feels depressing,
but we have nowhere to go but up. Okay. Which is another way to look at it.
It's kind of like type two would be more like solar power on
steroids.
Okay. Solar power on steroids. So it's like the sun,
but we're getting all of our power from the sun.
We're able to harness all that power from the sun and store it too.
Yes. And store it, which as you can imagine,
would allow us to do a whole bunch of things.
Not things that I would necessarily understand nor did I really understand this
prior to probably hours ago,
but that's why we have guests on the show because we want people to be able to
come on and explain some of these complicated topics.
Like what if earth became a type two civilization and in
case we're lucky enough to have somebody who's a bit of an expert on the subject
and who we've also had on the show before. Yeah, we have,
it's a professor Michio. Kaku, who's extremely.
Smart and well-respected.
And followed by a lot of people.
And really one of the people who are most cited and quoted when you're talking
about today's would, if, what if the earth became a type two civilization.
Michio Kaku is known as a futurist,
a great communicator and a popularizer of science.
He first graduated Summa laude from Harvard university in
1968 and received his PhD from Berkeley in 1972
CAC who has expertise in several fields, such as hydronic physics,
super symmetry, super gravity, super string theory and super quantum,
no, not super quantum physics, just quantum physics.
He's also quite the media Maven with multiple best-selling books to his name,
including his most recent, the future of humanity.
He also hosts two radio shows and appears regularly in television
series, exploring space physics and the future.
He's currently the city college of new York's Henry [inaudible] professor of
theoretical physics where he's been teaching for 35 years.
Professor. Kaku welcome back to what if discussed.
Glad to be on the show.
We're always glad to have you. And as Peter and I talked about off the top,
it's, it's a complicated subject. This type one type two civilizations.
If you don't know the Cartus Chev scale. Uh, and of course,
I think we did our best to try to understand it and explain it,
but this is why you're here because obviously this is something that you're
considered, uh, one of the experts on this planet. So first of all,
please clarify,
what is the Carter chef scale and what does the type one type two type three
civilization?
Well we've businesses are tired of talking about flying saucers and little
green men and speculating about life in space.
I'm a physicist. We use energy, energy
civilizations and outer space and type one. Civilization is planetary.
They consume all the energy that they be saved from the sun. For example,
they control the weather, but type two is stellar.
They control all the energy out, but of the mother's son,
sort of like the Federation of planets and star Trek,
they've colonized a few of the neighboring planets. They bring stars systems,
but not much more.
Then there's type three type three is galactic.
They roam the galactic space lanes.
They can harness the energy of a hundred billion stars in the galaxy,
sort of like a star Wars star Wars would be an example of a type
three galactic civilization. Now what are we do?
We play with the weather, play with volcanoes and play with earthquakes.
Do we play with the sun? Do we play with black holes throughout the galaxy?
No, we are type zero.
We don't even rate on this scale. We get our energy from dead plants,
oil and coal,
but we are about a hundred years away from attaining type one
status. For example, the internet, what is the internet?
It is the first type one telephone system to be
unleashed in this century.
What language will this type one civilization speak well already
English and Mandarin.
Chinese are the two greatest languages on the internet.
And what is the European union? What is NAFTA for all these trade blogs?
The beginning of a primitive type one planetary economy.
Now, if you keep the scale up,
at what point will we attain type two status that is
leave this solar system and start to explore the nearby stars? Well,
you just take out a slide rule or a calculator.
You can calculate that in just a few thousand years, we will be type two,
like captain Kirk, captain Kirk lives in the 23rd century.
So that's about right a little early,
but still well on this scale,
that decode card is shaft formulated and the 1960s.
Then you hit type three in about a hundred
thousand years. Wow. And why is that?
Because that's the energy that you attain the Planck energy.
The plunk energy is the energy of space.
Time is when space becomes unstable
wormholes develop black holes,
gateway hides per spatial, gateways through space and time.
That's the Planck energy.
The Planck energy is a quadrillion times more powerful than the large Hadron
Collider outside Geneva, Switzerland. And why do I mention that?
Because once you attain the plunk energy wormholes,
maybe even time-travel is a possibility. Wow.
Um, let's bring it back down to earth. And, uh, and, uh, talk about type two. I,
I was asking off the top,
whether a type two civilization was simply like solar power on
steroids.
Now I know you're not going to quote me in your next book as a genius insight,
but, uh, how close is that idea to, to, uh,
what type two means?
Well, type two does not mean simply getting sunlight from the sun.
It means playing with the sun itself. For example,
a Dyson sphere would envelop the entire sun with a
sphere to 100% of the energy
output of a star. That's a Dyson sphere.
And astronomers think that well, we're not sure,
but we may have the signals from some potential candidates of being a
type two civilization in outer space. There's a store called Tabby star,
which drops it intensity by about 25%.
Some people think that maybe a gigantic Jupiter sized planet moves in front
of this star or absorbing all this energy.
And perhaps that is a Dyson sphere in outer space,
but a type two civilization would be like star Trek.
And the Federation of planets they've colonized that small quadrant of the
galaxy would be a type two. Civilization.
Energy is something that we, I don't know it,
I don't mean we don't talk about energy because we talk about energy.
But as important as energy is to our day-to-day lives and our functions be
in on this planet, survival,
but even beyond you'd think we'd have even more focus.
I think we take it for granted. Obviously you walk into a room,
turn on a light switch, et cetera. But as you said earlier,
we w we still are at a, a pretty primitive level of harnessing energy,
which is again, fossil fuels.
How important is it that we let's say fast forward
our harnessing of solar power to not only get to type two
civilization one day, but to expedite the evolution of this species?
Well, let's take a look at it historically,
throughout most of human history for 99% of human history,
we had about a quarter of a horsepower per person,
the strength of your left hand and right hand.
And that's it folks that was the energy output for most of human
civilization, about a quarter of a horsepower.
There will be the investigated horses. About 10,000 years ago,
we went from a quarter of a horsepower to one horsepower.
And that began what is called civilization cities.
Armies empire has began to be formed. And then just 300 years ago,
we discovered the steam engine. And as a consequence,
we went from one horsepower to maybe 10 horsepower in a
buggy in a Moto. Now,
of course you have access to thousands of horsepower.
And in fact, we're going to use that energy to rocket into outer space.
So you see that the progress of civilization can be mapped by the
progress in energy,
harnessing that we've been able to harness thousands of horsepowers for what
astronaut,
while before it was only the strength of your left hand and your right hand.
Now you mentioned energy sources of the future. Solar is one,
but there's another one. I think that is even more important.
And that's fusion and fusion.
Power is still a few decades away,
but fusion power is the power of the universe. Wow.
That's what makes the sunshine is what makes the stars twinkle.
And we're going to be able to, I think in a few decades,
harness that fusion power on the planet,
or you give us unlimited amounts of energy from
seawater. Seawater is the basic fuel for fusion plants.
And we have one in France,
it's called the ITE E R FusionReactor in car dash France,
built by the European union with the help from the United States and Russia and
Japan. And we hope to get fusion off the ground in the coming decades.
Well, just so we book you in it far enough in advance,
just like you to put in your calendar that when that happens,
we'd like to have you back on the show cause ideally you and I would still be
alive. Peter, we'd still be doing what if discussed? But, uh, like right now,
I would say, let's just put a pin in that for now.
Let's say we jump in the time machine and go right there. The,
what if time machine Peter started up? Yes, we haven't used it in a while.
So let's say all the theoreticals are behind us.
We are now at that point where we are a type two civilization,
what are some of the kind of cool things that people would be sort of fascinated
by that a type two civilization as earth would be able to do,
whether it's controlling the weather, the atmosphere, uh, you know,
blowing asteroids out of the sky, look,
what are some of the things that we should be able to expect as a type two
civilization?
Well,
remember now we're talking about centuries to maybe a thousand years into the
future. Well,
we'll have pretty much colonized the entire solar system [inaudible] and
maybe out to the nearby stars. Uh,
we're going to build the first star ship perhaps within a hundred, 200 years.
NASA already has the 100 star 100 years starts your program looking
at potential propulsion systems for a star ship. Uh, for example,
anti-matter engines, uh, fusion engines, um,
even REM jet fusion engines. These are all possible engines for star ships.
Now we're not talking to warp drive to get work tribe.
You'd have to be type three,
but by the time you're type a one and aspiring toward type two,
this means building the first star ships.
So we're going to go far beyond the solar system and reach out to the nearby
stars. There's even a program called the breakthrough Starshot program. Uh,
Stephen Hawking, um,
my late colleague was a member of that program and he believed that,
yes, we should build the first star ship, not in a few hundred years,
but in this century, just in this century build the first star ship.
Okay.
Well, the,
one of the great things about having you is that regardless of where we're at
individually or collectively, I'm always optimistic,
excited after I S I speak to meet Shokaku because you see the future in such a
way that is, uh, especially in these times, uh,
encouraging and exciting. And,
and it gives us a reason to sort of, you know,
look forward beyond our sort of day-to-day problems and be excited about it's
interesting, because we talked about, you know,
homosapiens being around for 200,000 years and professor KAK, who's saying,
you know, all you had for power was horsepower,
and now we're a hundred years away. Probably yes. I mean,
a hundred years away, we couldn't fly or sorry, a hundred, you know,
a little over a hundred years ago, we couldn't fly. So, and then, you know,
50 years later, 60 years later, we're sending people to the moon. So as,
as you are always adept at doing,
you get us sort of steered in the right direction. We're going to have, uh,
professor Kaku on later. If you want to listen to this full in-depth interview,
beyond our conversation, that we just had click on the link below,
because a special treat, we are going to be breaking down,
uh, your most recent New York times bestseller the future of humanity.
I don't think it's overstating it to say that this is one of those times where
you want to be thinking about the future of humanity,
but especially the insights and the visionary, uh,
perspectives that you have in the book.
Give us a little idea of what we're going to be hearing about, uh,
and what people can expect to find in the book, the future of humanity.
Well, you know, the, the dinosaurs did not have a space program.
They're not here today.
There are no dinosaurs joining us for this interview today because they got
out, they were clueless. They didn't know what hit them. Well,
we do have a space program, and it's inevitable that we're going to have crises.
For example, volcanic eruptions, media impacts pandemics.
We know they're going to be crises of the future,
and we need an insurance policy,
an insurance policy to make sure that humanity survives,
no matter what catastrophes I hit the planet earth
and the main stumbling block preventing that was a four letter dirty word
costs.
It costs $10,000 to put a pound of anything into orbit around the planet earth.
That's your waiting goals. Think of your body may not have solid goals.
That's what it costs just to put you in orbit around the planet are well.
Now prices are dropping because Elon Musk and others
are perfecting the reusable rocket because of competition because of
private public collaboration,
the price of space travel is dropping like a rock.
This means that in the future, mom and dad may be able to go to outer space.
And I would even predict that our grandkids,
we have the option of honeymooning on the moon.
Cool. Not the dark side of the moon though.
Cause not a good way to start a relationship. So again,
more with Dr. [inaudible], uh, about everything,
future of humanity, you don't want to miss this.
So click on the link below and you're going to get a really in-depth dive into a
rabbit hole. That's going to cover so many topics about the short,
medium and longterm future of humanity on this planet. Uh,
Dr. Kaku talked about insurance policies, Peter,
it sounds like the perfect segue to talk about our friends at policy genius.
Professor CACO is not necessarily an insurance salesman, um, but is.
A genius possibly not a policy, definitely.
Not a policy genius.
Well policy genius is an insurance marketplace and there comes a time in life
when it becomes evident that people need some life insurance, but uh,
the world being a little topsy-turvy right now certainly is pandemic.
It's a deadly pandemic and you might be thinking, okay, well,
can you buy life insurance when there's a deadly pandemic?
Cause there is it inflated. They cover me. Well, the short answer is yes,
you can buy life insurance during a pandemic. And if you have loved ones,
depending on your income, it's a really good idea,
a best place to go for the best rate policy genius policy genius,
like I say is an insurance marketplace.
They're in contact with the life insurance companies on their platform every
day,
keeping track keeping track of the insurance market so that you don't have to,
they've got the expertise to cover you quickly.
And at the best price they compare quotes from the top life insurance companies,
all in one place just takes a few minutes to compare quotes from the top
insurers.
And that saves you a lot of legwork and it saves you a lot of money up to
$1,500 or more per year by using policy genius to compare life insurance policy.
So if you're looking to buy life insurance,
you're not sure where to start head on over to policy genius.com.
That'll get you and your family protected and hopefully give you one less thing
to worry about.
So yes,
I guess we have a lot to look forward to would be the glass half full because
we're type zero. As, as professor Kaku talked about,
we're hundreds of years away from probably being a type one and thousands of
years away from being a Titan.
This is like I mentioned, is this is, uh,
heartening for me as opposed to disheartening for me in that, like I said,
the human
homosapiens have been here for 200,000 years and all the progress we've made is
basically to get to here. And he thinks in a hundred years, 200 years,
we could be a type one civilization. My gosh,
like how incredible is that progression in 100 years compared to the last
200,000 years?
I'd love to see that on the news more, right? Yeah,
because it's so easy as he talked about that,
we get so focused on the present and you know, if you're a Zen Buddhist,
you'd say, well, that's where you want to be. You want to be in the moment,
but we also get fixated on this particular time as though this
is, you know, this is the,
the future of the is basically the next 10, no it's hundreds of years,
thousands of years, regardless of even what happens in the short term,
we in the planet are going to be around a long time in some form.
And it seems crazy obviously,
as we sit here today that the energy that we use and harness is still, you know,
as he said, like, you know, plants and, and,
and fossil fuels when you have the King dinosaur dinosaurs, decaying, dinosaurs,
and the focus on the sun, isn't new, but hearing this, you think, man,
if we really focused all our attention on solar power and then, you know,
further harnessing that power.
So we've got this enormous yellow burning ball of
energy that I can feel on my face. I walked down the street,
it's burning all day long. I mean, certainly we are earth rotates,
but why are we not expanding all our energy,
expanding all our energy into capturing the energy from something that's free,
something that's incredibly powerful and something that's so close rather than
like, you know,
bugging around with all this junk underneath the dirt.
We're the only species in the world that actually has the ability to
delay its own evolution.
Because we have, we've known this for 15.
The 60 years that obviously there's a way to get solar power, uh, you know,
make it ubiquitous around the world and essentially make energy as close to free
as possible. But our focus hasn't been there, our focus has been in other ways.
And of course, once you have that link to your economy,
nobody's in a rush to sort of change the status quo.
And that's kind of been the case. I think though, not only is though is the,
will there by most people or many people around the world.
I think starting to see that the, the, the political currency is there as well.
So I think we're doing the show in 10 years.
It's a different story because I think we're going to be way further down the
line on way more solar and wind.
I mean, 10 years, we're 10 years closer to that, you know,
30 years in which we're all gonna die and don't stop burning fossil fuels
and treating the planet. Like we.
I don't have a great history as being proactive,
but we have a pretty good history as being reactive.
We, the only, uh, species that could end our own evolution as well.
I would think so outside of lemmings, I think lemonade can just run off.
Cliffs, but it has a whole, I mean, all over the world,
they can't coordinate there. There's no.
I mean, it's, it's, it's funny.
Cause we're supposed to be the smartest species in the world.
Yet we have that unique ability, which is you could argue, not smart.
Exactly. If you want more with professor Meteo CAC, who, like we said,
there's the full audio podcast,
click on the link below and you'll get about 20 more minutes with us. And, uh,
professor Michio, Kaku, it's going to be really interesting. Trust me.
Talking about the future of humanity, which we're kind of doing here,
but of course at a kindergarten level.
So if you want to hear somebody who really has an incredibly visionary
perspective,
an exciting and optimistic perspective on the future of the species, humanity,
the planet, et cetera, you're going to want to stick around for this.
Cause again, every time we talked to meet you, Okaka we, we usually leave,
you know, kind of you smiling and feeling a lot better about things.
Which he's,
he's talking about things that make you happy rather than it's not the end of
the world for him. It's the possibilities of what we can do. Well said, Peter,
what are the possibilities of you coming back and watching another?
What if discussed maybe next week? Well, why don't you, because this one's over.
Thanks for joining us here on what if discussed.